many legends ago legend stole love a man
so strong so brave so handsome a man
that changed the world but this was not
that man this was that man his name was
honored
when the world changed
Arnold knew he had one purpose to become
the Governor of California and that's
what he sought out to become Arnold said
goodbye to his weapon
Arnold left his past behind all he
needed to change the world was himself
and his awesome pecs
he ran oh he ran
much worse dodge our needed to
investigate
injustice our loads change the world
one knuckle at a time
stop resisting Jesus Christ
punched him right in the knee gets them
every time
punch his knee you just took an Arnold
to the knee [ __ ] all new to become
governor of Alaska he had to cleanse his
lands if there was no one else but
Arnold in Alaska then he would become
the principal a knife or the [ __ ]
weapon take that
what's going on are we getting out of
here
shut up all new to become governor of
Alaska indeed he needed to give people
their freedom he needed to suit up
that's just very good at a good oh that
is very good [ __ ] yes
hasta la vista
huh-uh no this here to bring justice on
these lands justice more justice Jesus
Christ what was that holy [ __ ]
fight me like a man
ah oh no don't like
while you're on [ __ ] come back here I
punch your ass oh that's right
[ __ ] take this
oh hey stop i [ __ ] them oh that's
awesome
Oh Shay where the [ __ ] are you going man
stay down [ __ ] hahahaha oh it's
awesome
he can't move my candidates vote for me
what formula you think you can beat
Arnold the [ __ ] is she doing oh no no
you had to go to the big city if we
wanted to win the election what the [ __ ]
is this too ugly to live bra bra bra
Jesus what the [ __ ] deaf you didn't see
anything
dammit we ran out of power
that's okay
I'll run faster alone Oh God
the [ __ ] are you ugly ugly marriages
Diamond City just as Arnold remembered
it or a piece of [ __ ] whoa there's a
boat
anonymous investigate could be potential
voters have you heard about our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ [ __ ] you don't know
who you're [ __ ] with this is the city
Arnold needed to protect where are you
running
where are you running this is awkward
Arnold finally made it to the Parliament
this is where he belonged oh my god
I want the hammer give me that hammer oh
hell yeah whoo shooting excuse me
sit down
my fellow Americans I should become
president of this town no one listened
to Arnold and it was at that moment all
not realized stop it
justice lacinato chance